south africa's western cape
is notoriously dangerous almost
one in four of all fatal great white
attacks
happen here in other parts of the world
the most dangerous time to enter the
water is at dawn
or dusk the times when white sharks
typically hunt
but these waters are different
investigators have identified that the
majority of the attacks on the western
cape
take place during the day this
surprising anomaly
could be the key to solving the mystery
behind the attacks
mike baron is a marine biologist living
in cape town for the past two years
he's been studying the oceanic
ecosystems of the western cape
mike believes part of the answer lies in
an incredible aspect of south africa's
marine ecology so today
we're going to drop down and we're going
to monitor one of my favorite places to
dive it's a really amazing
magical place
these are south africa's kelp forests
each strand of this giant seaweed
measures up to 40 feet tall
and grows in dense clusters stretching
over 600 miles
creating a vast underwater wonderland
all the different complexities of life
down there and
a fantastic area to dive and research
the kelp forests are home to all manner
of oceanic life
but there's one species that lives here
of particular significance
when it comes to sharks cape fur seals
white sharks are often seen patrolling
the edges of kelp forests
looking for the cape fur seal until
recently it was believed that great
whites patrolled the edges of the kelp
forests at dawn
and dusk but rarely ventured in
the sun's low position in the sky was
thought to help them
pick out the silhouettes of unsuspecting
seals as they
exited the forest but in 2019
a study emerged that turned traditional
thinking about great white's hunting
patterns
on its head in 2019 researchers were
conducting head study on great white
sharks
they attached some cameras to the dorsal
fins
and the footage that came back was very
unusual
they actually found that these sharks
were moving into quite dense kelp forest
areas
and even hunting seals which previously
we thought was not happening in seoul
and most importantly the sharks were
seen to be hunting during the day
not just at dawn and dusk this new
revelation in shark research means that
all the way through today wherever
there's kelp there's potentially white
sharks
cruising around looking for their seal
south africa is one of a few countries
in the world
that has natural kelp forests right on
its coast
kelp grows all along the beaches here in
the western cape right from the
intertidal zone
in very highly populated beaches as well
there's lots of people swimming surfing
and diving in the kelp forests right
along the coasts
this means that every day at any time
the sharks are patrolling the coastline
of the western cape
looking for seals in the exact same
waters
used by people
[Music]
you